ken and Nicole are in the lobby of
financial peace Plaza
hey guys how are you hey we're doing
really well how are you I am better than
I deserve welcome to Nashville where do
you guys live we live in Byron Center
Michigan it's just outside of Grand
Rapids we've been together since high
school
we're highschool sweethearts been
married three and a half years and we've
recently become debt-free in August
well congratulations welcome we
appreciate you visiting so you're here
to do your debt-free scream we are
that is awesome so how much have you
paid off well Dave we paid off a hundred
and nine thousand dollars twenty
thousand of which was student loan debt
for my wife here and eighty nine
thousand was our house our mortgage
you've paid off your mortgage yeah your
three and a half years out of high
school no no no sweetheart okay all
right and so how old are you I'm 24 I'm
25 okay when did you get married in 2010
okay and so you've been married three
years and some change okay and so this
whole time you've been working on this
get out of debt plan yeah three and a
half years from the time you got married
on and it was the house and the student
loan yes and I'm sorry and we cash
flowed $38,000 with the repairs on the
house Wow and what was your household
income during the last 3 and 1/2 years
we started out at 58,000 and now we're
at 78,000 excellent what do you guys do
for a living I do home remodeling I run
my own business called Zachman home
remodeling and I do custom kitchens and
bathrooms and just about anything in a
house really good for you
and I also make some extra income I make
custom caskets oh ok cool cool
and Nicole what do you do I'm a creative
consultant for an organization in
Michigan and I'm also known as West
Michigan's luxury image director I help
entrepreneurs visually brand their
services to attract their ideal clients
Wow
very cool look at you - you're amazing
very neat so what happened I mean you're
getting married you're just out there
you're a normal young couple and then
you decide we're gonna be weird we're
gonna pay off our house fast we're not
only gonna knock out these student loans
Nichole's but we're gonna pay off our
house fast what happened what made you
believe you could do that we knew that
moving forward that with the goals and
the dreams and the passions that we
wanted to have in our careers that we
needed to to pay off this debt so that
we could move forward and then after we
paid off so that we realized how much of
an inspiration we could be to others and
just seeing everyone else around us
acknowledging that we were able to do
this we want to we just want others to
know that they can do it too as long as
they make the right behavioral choices
and make it a priority
anyone can do it doesn't matter if you
are single have a family or it just
doesn't matter you can do it with God's
help that's pretty amazing
what was the hardest dirtiest nastiest
horrible thing you had to do in the last
three and a half years to get out of
that day we made a lot of sacrifices
what was the one that you just go oh
yeah we have we've driven many old
vehicles your driveway was hoop deville
I love it were they tell me about them
what was the worst one probably the 98
prism we have but I have a little
Cherokee Jeep 98 Jeep now and he's got
two old Suburbans I want to use this for
his work and then the other is in case
the other one breaks down no you got an
old suburban when you have a spare yeah
I love it
and how old is I old are they ones that
my work trucks in 94 yeah and my other
trucks in 99 yeah so you have cars
almost as old as you
yeah totally making fun of you aren't
they yeah I'm sure
you're awesome thank you yeah and now
you can buy anything you want to buy
because you can save up you don't even
have a house payment you're so
incredible yes well you don't even have
a house payment when did you pay off the
house when well what day it was three
days for my birthday in August you
wanted to do it before you turned 25 and
yeah that's 25 year old too old
yeah I'm just gonna pay off my house by
the time I'm 24 you guys I love ya
you're incredible so what made you
believe you could really pull this off
actually it's from listening to you Dave
listen for a lot of years now actually
since you came on in Grand Rapids and
I've heard people at callin that make
way less than have we do and they paid
off their house and done other crazy
stuff so we said hey we can do this and
we can do it fast so your mom and dad
did you grow up this way were they
supportive or what my mom kind of was I
don't know that anyone else really
believed that we were gonna do it yeah
until you did it okay
and what's the house worth its worst
about 120,000 phenomenal you guys are
that's a great house in that area it's
not bad at all not bad at all
I mean a lot of 25 year olds would be
just happy to have that house much less
have it paid for yeah that's just
stinking awesome I love it
very very cool so what do you tell
people that the keys to getting out of
debt are sacrificed and cutting out
things that aren't necessity we found
out over the three years that not having
a washer and dryer not having a
dishwasher a little thing and we have
them now but we earned and saved and
then purchased them we didn't go out and
buy brand-new furniture for our house we
paid for things as we had the money and
so just doing everything you can to stay
out of debt and paying off the debt that
you have and it's it's really liberating
and freeing so you have sacrificed
deeply you really have but you're really
saying it was worth it it was very worth
it
mm-hmm here you sit without a house
payment amazing you guys are awesome
what a what an inspiring couple you're
just you're on top of it yeah I think I
may use that now that may be one
indication that you're probably on the
Dave Ramsey plan if your cars are older
than you are that's not bad that's not a
bad line at all right there I like that
oh you might be on the Dave Ramsey plan
if yeah we need to fill those in on
Twitter
but it's a temporary thing if you drive
like no one else later you can drive
like no one else I drove a car like that
man it had a four hundred seventy eight
thousand miles on it
predominant color was bondo that was it
I did that I did it I felt like four
years but all it was was just for a few
months while we cleaned up and saved up
and moved ourselves along you know we
just vowed we weren't borrowing money
anymore so well done you two well done
alright Kenan Nicole rock stars from
Grand Rapids Michigan 24 25 years old a
hundred and nine thousand dollars paid
off in three and a half years by the way
that's their house and everything fifty
eight thousand now making seventy eight
thousand a year count it down let's hear
a debt free scream three two
great job you too great job I love it
that's fun fun fun fun stuff very well
done
well you can do it if they can do it I
don't make five hundred thousand dollars
a year they make fifty eight thousand
and they made seventy eight thousand
they're turned 25 years old pay off
their house and you know people are
wondering when you're driving a 94
suburban you know they're making rolling
their eyes you know they are I mean
seriously
that's an old car
it's it does it sounds weird for me to
say that that's an old car but it is an
old car and you know you can do it
though for a period of time I don't want
you to live like that your whole life I
want you to live like no one else so
later you can live and give like no one
else and that's where they are they're
ready to win they're able to do anything
they want to do from this point forward